aquí tenemos las gráficas de dos curvas
estamos acostumbrados a ver cosas que
son funciones de x pero aquí tenemos a x
como función de y podemos escribir esta
expresión como f de iu y esta otra para
diferenciar la la podemos escribir como
g de y nuevamente es una función de g en
este vídeo vamos a tratar de encontrar
el área que está resaltada en azul entre
estas dos curvas los invito a que pausa
en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo una
gran pista aquí es que vamos a querer
integrar con respecto a esta es una
integral definida cuyos límites están en
términos de g por ejemplo este punto de
intersección abajo será nuestro límite
inferior en términos de g le llamamos de
1 y esto de aquí arriba será nuestro
límite superior en términos de ya que
llamamos de 2 si pensamos en donde se
intersectan ésta
dos curvas y vemos las coordenadas de
estas intersecciones tendremos los
límites para nuestra integral es una
integral definida que va de 1 a 2 vamos
a integrar con respecto a y de g que es
lo que vamos a sumar cuando integramos
podemos pensar que vamos a sumar el área
de rectángulos infinitamente delgados en
este caso serán rectángulos
infinitamente planos ya que están con
respecto a deje de ser a la altura de
estos rectángulos y en este caso cuál
será la base en este intervalo entre 1 y
nuestra función azul efe tiene valores
más grandes en x kg de g por lo que esta
longitud de aquí es f de este valor de x
menos este otro valor de x que es gd y
esto será efe - g de g
conocemos que es f aquí lo importante es
encontrar estos puntos de intersección
veamos en donde se intersectan estas dos
curvas
ambas son iguales a x x
que estas dos expresiones son iguales
entre sí sabemos que al cuadrado más
tres porque más 11 es igual a esto y al
cuadrado más menos 1 restemos todo esto
de ambos lados para tener un 0 de este
lado y nos quede una ecuación cuadrática
del lado izquierdo restamos - cuadrada
menos 1 y escribimos lo mismo del otro
lado esperemos que nos quede una
ecuación cuadrática directa veamos aquí
nos queda menos 2 porque al cuadrado más
2 porque más 12 igual a 0 y aquí puedo
factorizar un -2 y nos queda menos 2 x
al cuadrado menos 10 menos 6 igual a
cero esto lo podemos factorizar muy
fácilmente tenemos que pensar en que par
de números al sumarlos nos da menos uno
y al multiplicarlos nos da menos seis
serán menos tres y dos nos queda menos
dos que multiplica al menos tres por dos
esto viene de una factorización directa
de una
ecuación cuadrática lo que es igual a
cero cuáles son los puntos de
intersección estos puntos serán igual a
tres y que igual a menos dos esto de
aquí es igual a menos dos y el límite
superior será igual a tres
ahora tenemos que evaluar esto de menos
2 a 3 vamos a hacer lo voy a quitar todo
esto para tener más espacio para
escribir esto es igual a la integral que
va de menos 2 a 3 de menos al cuadrado
más tres por más
11 - hebei y distribuimos el signo
negativo lo que nos queda menos y al
cuadrado menos más uno y tenemos deje
esto es igual a la integral definida que
va de menos 2 a 3 de menos cuadrada
menos cuadrada es menos dos por de
cuadrada más 3% menos es 2% y finalmente
11 más uno es igual a 12 ya habíamos
visto esto cuando despejamos
y aquí será igual esto calculamos la
anti derivada de esto y es menos 2
incrementamos el exponente y al cubo y
lo dividimos entre ese exponente 3
aplicamos el inverso de la regla de la
potencia más 2 porque al cuadrado entre
2 nos da y al cuadrado nuevamente
aplicamos el inverso de la regla de la
potencia más 12 porque esto lo evaluamos
en 3 y en menos 2 si lo evaluamos en 3
nos queda menos 2 por 27 entre 39 más 36
y a esto le restamos todo esto evaluado
en menos dos menos dos por menos ocho
entre 34 menos 24 27 entre 39 por lo que
tenemos menos 2 por 9 que nos da menos
18 más 9 nos da menos 9 más 36 nos da 27
todo esto de color azul ahora veamos lo
de color rojo negativo por negativo 16
entre
es 424 nos da 16 entre 3 menos 20 pero
también tenemos este signo negativo aquí
lo distribuimos y nos queda más 20 y en
lugar de tener este 16 entre 3 lo
reescribimos como cinco y un tercio
menos cinco y un tercio que es igual
esto movemos esto para tener un poco más
de espacio nos queda 47 menos 5 menos un
tercio
veamos 47 5 es 42 menos un tercio nos da
41 y dos tercios y con esto terminamos